-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with the one and only Tariq Trotter!
♪♪
And we're about to play a game of "Pictionary."
But to do that, we're going to need some teammates here.
First, joining Tariq's team, his new movie,
"Somewhere in Queens," hits theaters tomorrow.
Please welcome Ray Romano!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow! -All right.
I hope you can draw. -Good to see you, bud.
-How are you? How are you? -Good to see you, pal.
Look at that. Come on. Come on.
That's what I'm talking about.
Joining my team, she's the creator and star
of the new series, "Slip."
Please welcome Zoe Lister-Jones!
[ Cheers and applause ]
No! Come on! The best, buddy.
Zoe, Ray -- Zoe. Come on.
All right.
Look at that. They love you. All right.
Everyone knows how to play "Pictionary."
30 seconds on the clock.
We'll each take a turn, and then we'll have a showdown
where both teams will draw at the same time,
the same clue, worth double the points.
And may the best team win.
Ray, why don't you go first here?
-I just want to say I'm bad at this.
-No, you can't say that. -More than anyone
has been bad at this. -Okay. Here you go.
You feel confident? -Absolutely.
-All right, good. Let's go. -Pick up the slack.
You got to pick up slack. -You got this.
-So, audience, you want to tell him what clue?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Oh, I pick a number? -You pick a clue.
-I hear 4, I hear 4.
-All right. And don't show it. -No, I look.
It is an action. -You can start guessing now
if you want, Tariq. [ Laughter ]
-Moving. -It's drawing. Drawing.
-Exactly. Here he goes. Ray Romano.
-Oh, did the clock start yet? -Yes.
Ray Romano playing "Pictionary." [ Laughter ]
This is fantastic.
-Roller skating. -Other people have to
see this, Ray. -Right. Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Paint drying, grass growing, mountains.
Uh... Okay.
-Maybe we should guess, too. -Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-There doesn't seem to be that much urgency to it.
-Tariq, I know what that is.
-Cookie Monster. A fried egg.
Eggs and bacon. [ Cheers and applause ]
-You got it! -Fried egg? Yeah, yeah, cool.
-They got it! Dude, come on!
Not bad. -[ Laughs ]
-Yeah. The first egg was too perfect.
-Right. -That was too good.
That's -- Yeah.
-The second one sealed the deal. -Yeah, that second one.
-That was frying a doughnut.
[ Laughter ]
-Fried doughnut. Guys, what number?
What do you think? [ Audience shouting ]
I love 9. I love 9. I love 9.
Phrase. -Okay.
-Narrows it down. -Oh, boy.
-All right. We got this. -Yeah, we got this.
-Ready? -Yeah.
-Okay. Here we go. Um...
-Where's the clock? Is there a clock?
-Phrase. Paper bag.
Cat's out of the bag.
Uh...shopping bag.
Can't -- Can't --
Easter Bunny. Bunny shopping.
Bunny shop. Bunny hop.
U... Ugh!
What? Can't --
Hearing impaired.
Hearing impaired bag bunny. -No.
[ Laughter ]
-No, bag, bag. Paper, paper! [ Buzzer ]
-Can I guess? Can I guess? -Yeah, can I? Can I?
-You guess first, but don't say if it's right or not.
-Okay. -Paper or plastic.
-Oh!
-Is it "Somewhere in Queens"?
[ Laughter ]
I have to plug the movie!
-You can't plug your movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have no money for advertising.
-It's not "Somewhere in Queens," his movie.
-It was "Paper or plastic." Tariq, that is correct.
Sorry. I know. -I'm sorry.
-I messed up. I can't write words.
I can't write words. -Oh, you can't write words.
-Which one? Which one we going for, folks?
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Both laugh ]
-I'mma go with 5, I'mma go 5.
Okay. This is an action.
-Got it.
[ Audience groans, laughter ]
-Mm.
♪♪
-"Somewhere in Queens"!
-No, you can't keep saying "Somewhere in Queens"!
-We have no money for advertising.
Uh, diving.
Diving.
Oh, boy. Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wow.
That's something in prison. Something in prison.
[ Laughter ]
-"Somewhere in Queens" is your movie.
-Yeah, "Somewhere in Queens." -Not "Something in Prison."
Tumblesault. -Oh! Dang.
'Cause I was gonna do this.
And then you probably would've got it, you know?
-Wait. What's that?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
-Well, I would be... [ Laughter ]
I gotta be honest.
I would be scared if I got it from that.
[ Laughter ]
-If -- If I --
-That -- That would've given him the answer?
-I don't know, man! But here's the thing.
You could sense the urgency.
Yes. This is downward dog.
Yes, downward dog. -Downward dog, yo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Downward dog. Got it.
-Oh. -Just in case kids are watching,
I want to clear that up. -Is it me? Am I going?
-Zoe, you are up. Zoe, come on.
-Okay. Okay. -We're up one-nothing still.
-Yep.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Okay. Foof.
All right. -Category.
-Category's object. -Object, yeah.
-Okay. -Ray, you can't say
"Somewhere in Queens" -I won't. I won't.
-You can't guess on this one. This is just.
-Okay. -We got this. Object.
Zoe, we got this, bud. -Okay.
-Yes. Freckles.
-Cookie. -Questlove's new book!
-Chocolate chip cookie. -No.
Cookie dough. -Um, uh...
-Cookie Monster. Cookie...
-Uh... -Cookie show.
Julia Child.
Um...baker.
-Oh, I got it.
-Chef, baker, cookie.
-No. -Cook, chef, Food Network.
-Oh! -That's an object.
Host. -Okay. Uh-huh.
[ Buzzer ] -Ugh!
-We know it. -Oh, you did it?
-We know it. -How do you know it again?
-Yeah. Like, we'd like to take it.
[ Laughter ] -You'd like to take it.
-We'd like to steal, please! -Yes.
-Yes. What's your answer? -We're allowed one steal.
-Girl Scout Cookie.
[ Dinging ]
Whoo! -How do you do it, man?
-It's over. Game over, game over.
-No, it's not game over. No, no.
No, no. It's not game over.
No, that was very good. Not game over.
Because here's what makes it fun, this game.
-But we won. -Kind of. You won so far.
But now here's the fun thing.
We're going to do one last round, okay?
And whoever wins this wins the whole game.
[ Laughter ]
-Do I need to draw "Somewhere from Queens"?
-No! -Come on. Come on, Ray.
Come on. -Okay.
-Okay. You pick. -We swap?
[ Audience shouting ] -You go that side.
-You're hot. You're hot tonight.
What is going down? You're hot tonight.
-Ugh. Nightmare.
-All right. This is an action.
-I've never done it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
Uh...
Oh, spring.
Spring, uh, forward. -Spring awakening!
Spring, spring back! Spring forward!
Spring break! Spring, spring...
-Spring, uh... Spring, uh...
-Come on, Ray! Do another thing!
-Spring -- Spring sweep. Spring sweep.
Spring cleaning! [ Dinging ]
Spring cleaning!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Ray... [ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry.
-You didn't get that?! You didn't get spring cleaning?
-You got to give me something, man!
Come on. -Spring cleaning.
-I thought it was spring peeing.
-Oh, man.
-My thanks to Ray Romano, Zoe Lister-Jones.
We're talking to Ray after the break.
Stick around, everybody.